hey wassup my name is Samuel Leeds and
on a property investor and I am this
week going to be answering all of your
niggly property questions now I'm going
to answer them and I'm gonna do the same
thing next week so if you want me to
answer your questions comment them below
to this video
anything property related and I'll do my
best to answer that next week so this
week what have we got so I've got some
really interesting questions from the
other week know
Rafik said samuel great workers usual
boom thanks man would you look at lease
holt when considering a lease option
agreement or is it strictly free Holtz
okay so the difference between a
leasehold property and a freehold
property freehold you're buying the
property and you're also buying the land
that the property sits on leasehold
you're not buying the land you're
actually although you're buying the
property the land technically you're in
its lease so you don't own it you're
just renting it and what I would say is
don't buy lease don't buy leasehold
property unless number one there's a lot
of years left on the lease if the lease
is going to run out in your lifetime so
maybe if you if you're a bit older even
in your kids lifetime then don't buy it
so if I'm buying a leasehold property I
want it to be like maybe 99 years left
on the lease or more if there's 40 years
left on the lease it's it's just it's
just not gonna it's just not going to
work also as well that when you buy a
leasehold property well you will have to
pay a peppercorn service charge ground
rent so just make sure that's really
really really small and just check the
legalities on that with your solicitor
before you buy a leasehold property
however if you're making money on it and
the lease is really really long and it's
gonna far outlive you and maybe even
your children then I wouldn't I wouldn't
say don't ever buy leasehold property
you know if you still making money on it
you're still buying it can be good so
it's the same if you're doing a lease
option agreement it's the same story
what I would say is I I favor freehold
but if you're going to make if you're
gonna be doing a lease option on a
leasehold then you're gonna be making
money as long as my solicitors happy and
I'm making money I'm happy that's kind
of my answer really I hope that helps
Pye says I have a plan and was wondering
if you could let me know if this is a
good plan
okay so I'm looking to join the Armed
Forces but would like to save up a
deposit for a buy to let mortgage on a
two-bedroom house after a few years of
owning the property and renting it out
I'd like to refinance the property and
take out the equity and then use that
money to buy a second property for
either myself or to rent out your videos
really helpful thanks in advance okay
thanks great question what I would say
is your plan is not great it's not great
because you're relying on the on the
house going up in value just over time
we've cut as we've capital appreciation
which is not a dead cert you're just
hoping that it is so this strategy that
you're saying is what a lot of people do
accidentally so they'll buy a house for
a hundred grand and then a few years
later it's now gone up it's now over one
hundred and thirty and they go home nice
and then they just get a new mortgage on
it they pull out their equity and then
they're buy another house and that works
organically almost accidentally and
people do that however if you're saying
that that's what you that's your plan a
and you're just relying on the capital
appreciation it's not really a great
plan because it might not happen and
it's also really really slow so it's
just going to take years what I would
probably say will be better is if you
buy a house and then you buy it knowing
that there's a problem with the house
and you can solve that problem and add
value straight away so let's just say
that there I mean it could even just be
that it's not in good condition it could
be that you buy a house for instead of
buying it for a hundred you buy the 80
grand but there's no kitchen and
bathroom in the house so it's unmoor
reachable so you buy it on a short-term
bridging loan you get a nice kitchen a
nice bathroom you add value and then you
would finance it quicker because you've
bought the value but that probably does
take more education more knowledge to do
that but you're in control you're not
just relying on the economy going up so
I'd probably look at getting getting
some good education and you speed the
process but however the just buying a
house that makes money and doing it the
slow way that's not bad it just could be
a lot better thanks man i pushing a
question mark kenan says how do you keep
your return on investment on a buy to
let after your initial low rate mortgage
goes up do you remove it and keep doing
it every two or five years okay so
you're assuming that the
it just rates out always going up
they're not sometimes they go down
sometimes they go option because they go
down at the moment interest rates are it
they've gone up in a little bit recently
but they're pretty low still so they
probably will go up in time but what I
find is that my return on investment
usually as years year-on-year on happens
and happens normally my return on
investment goes up because rents go up
and you can fix interest rates and yeah
you can refinance of course you know
after a few years you go from a
fixed-rate on to a variable and then the
variables fly in you're like oh man yeah
absolutely just just fix again you get a
new mortgage or if you've got equity in
the property get a mortgage and pull
that equity out billion percent but
generally speaking every year or two
you're gonna have a little rent increase
as well which is gonna mean that your
ROI is going up so it just depends how
do you how do you track it every year
just have a spreadsheet every year or
even every month just putting on how
much did you
what were your expenses that month on
the property and what was your profit
that meant from the on the property is a
business do a profit and loss sheet
check it out check it's okay and yeah so
I hope that helps I wouldn't overthink
it and don't forget to do rent reviews
when your properties as well as interest
payment reviews as well next excellent
advice I've been interested in
properties as I watched property
development abroad about ten years ago
life to the swinging want to get into it
now I like the sound of lease option
agreements am I right in that to start
one the required payment are as follows
okay so if you're going to be doing a
lease option agreement you need one
solicitor fees two monthly payment to
the person we buy the property off
that's it
then we rent it out as multi rents Steve
kind of so sister fees yes when you do a
lease option agreement you're gonna need
to pass list of fees and that's usually
around about seven hundred and fifty
pounds to a thousand pounds the monthly
payments to the person you buy the
property off that's not an upfront
payment that that's like you're gonna
get tenant and you're gonna pay them
monthly so that's just an ongoing cost
so the costs upfront
our sister fees also if you're doing if
you can lead to do any work to the
property or if you're doing it as if you
turning into HMO you know need to
obviously budget for furniture and he
works to the property the the seller
might require an upfront fee as well in
fact
sometimes it's just a pound but you'll
always need to pay something could be
just a pound or it could be a thousand
pounds depends on what you negotiate so
basically with a lease option agreement
it's the same with buying a house but
you just don't pay the deposit so you
won't pay any deposit up front which is
the big chunk of money you might still
everything else survey for instance I
would still recommend getting a survey
on the property because just because
it's a free house doesn't mean that it's
a good house so you know checks on it
survey sister fees you need to pay but
it's nominal right it might be like a
few thousand pounds and for a house for
a few thousand pounds is not bad I'll do
one more quick one sim songs great
advice from Grant Cardone yeah grant
grant is a beast and I've loved I've
loved meeting him and learning from him
I'd love to see you get one-to-one
advice from Tony Robbins he charges 1
million pounds or which should Bandler
what do you think yeah absolutely I'll
be very I'd love to I'd love to do some
training with Tony Robbins I mean a
million pounds I know Tony charges a
million pounds for a one-on-one session
geez I mean you've even stretching my
brain now I mean I paid I paid a hundred
thousand for Grant Cardone and I
actually paid grant two hundred thousand
because I'm doing some other stuff and
some of those training a million jeez
it's crazy because I spend all this
money on all these mentors and then I
teach you the stuff for free so I hope
you appreciate it subscribe share the
video drop your questions below as well
your questions and comments and I look
forward seeing you next time thanks so
much
you